in the mood for something different why
not try four player chess where three
opponents are better than one in four
player chess you do battle on a special
board earning points by capturing active
enemy pieces pawns are worth 1 point
Knights are worth 3 bishops and rooks
are worth five Queens are worth nine and
Kings are valued at 20 points your pawns
will also automatically promote to
Queens on your eighth rank but promotive
Queens are with just one point one
captured you can capture Kings in four
player chests but a regular checkmate
will earn twenty points too you'll also
get 20 points if your opponent resigns
and you are the last player standing
however if there are multiple players
still active after someone resigns the
defeated King must be captured to get
the 20 points finally some special
situations can earn points without a
capture a stalemate will award 10 points
to all remaining players you can also
get bonus points by checking multiple
Kings with the same move five points for
a double check and 15 for a triple check
the player with the most points at the
end wins the game good luck